euh le chanteur Salvatore Salvatore
Adamo a déclaré le soutenance
euh sur battle Laurent Ruquier avoir une
particularité physique mais laquelle
regardez
alors c'est pas la laisser jouer la
Marseillaise avec ses aisselles il a
trois tétons il a les cheveux gris
depuis sa naissance ou il ne respire que
d'une narine
il ne respire que d'une narines
depuis sa naissance
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas couché avec lui
tu fais ce que tu veux le troisième
téton
c'est pas très grave mais il était
l'invité voilà de des Enfants de la télé
il a précisé ses petits trucs regardé
Salvatore à la même particularité
physique étonnante corne d'eau le frère
de David
c'est vrai bien sûr bien sûr c'est vrai
j'ai la même particularité vous pouvez
m'ajouter à la liste Orlando aussi vous
avez vous pouvez le dire oui bien sûr
alors allez-y j'ai trois seins
c'est moins ennuyeux pour moi que pour
une cousine germaine qui a trois seins
si Salvatore à 3 tétons et je vois sur
mes fiches que j'ai le je vois sur mes
fiches que j'ai le cirque Pinder parce
qu'on m'a mis les les particularités des
chroniqueurs c'est hallucinant Florian
moi j'ai les pieds très larges parce
qu'en fait je suis né avec une petite
malformation c'est-à-dire que j'avais
les pieds un peu comme ça donc on va
aller
Jean-Michel
très très large ça donne c'est génial à
Paris ça sert à rien mais c'est à dire
je mais ça va ça va la photo grossit un
petit peu quand même alors Isabelle
attends j'ai trois fiches euh non
Isabelle c'est quoi
arrive à mon âge déjà j'ai les bras
l'axe
parce que mon seul point faible c'est la
gym à l'époque et je leur ai dit je peux
pas regarder mes bras
j'ai mis son tendus
à l'envers c'est dingue comme ça c'est
Madame Patate
alors bah dis donc c'est intéressant
tout le nez il est là là il est
d'origine je suis née avec
une caméra ici
Jean-Jacques
il y a d'autres petites choses avec
quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
particularité arrête non vraiment je te
dirai tu as trois couilles
non il y a ça Christopher c'est
retourner ses doigts à 90
mais quelqu'un normal ici
et Sophie évidemment on demande une
particularité physique et tout de suite
on est dans le
défilé Balmain tout le temps elle va
comme ça je te dis pas de déshabiller un
peu les seins une baguette
elle a un tatouage sur l'orteil oui
bon on passe à autre chose parce que moi
j'avais une anecdote mais elle paiera
pas la productrice donc plutôt de lui
faire faire un point de montage